pourrait condenser quand même mené
l'algérie jouant m après deux benhaim et
1 et la voilà vous d'aller danser
regardez on peut quand même un peu
denses et c'est parti music hall et
musicale
[Musique]
s'cusez moi frères ta demande c'était
dedans c'est qu'il faut faire ça mr ne
baisse jamais en fait c'est zéro parce
que je t'aime énormément mais là moi je
m'attendais je me suis dit le gars il a
des mocassins antidérapant il est au top
il choque des meubles dans le bruce et
là tu arrives et bim tu me fais ça allez
on y va c'est pas dans ce que je voulais
faire ce que tu veux m'a dit allez vas-y
alesi hockey danser et merci merci mon
look et hop